plusieurs millions de personnes dans le monde.
En second :
trouver ou proposer une solution radicale pour le résoudre.
Et en troisième :
avoir des raisons de croire
que des techniques applicables à cette solution radicale,
pourraient être créées.
J'ai un secret à vous révéler.
Notre usine Moonshot est désordonnée.
Mais plutôt que d'éviter ce désordre,
de prétendre qu'il n'existe pas,
nous en avons fait notre force.
Nous passons la plupart de notre temps à casser des choses,
à nous prouver que nous avons tout faux.
Et c'est ça le secret.
Regarder d'abord les difficultés.
Être enthousiaste, soutenir le projet,
se demander de quelle manière nous allons le détruire aujourd'hui !
Nous maintenons un équilibre intéressant :
nous autorisons notre optimisme à se déployer pour alimenter nos idées ;
mais nous nous attachons à un scepticisme enthousiaste
pour que nos projets conservent un certain réalisme.
Je voudrais vous parler de projets
que nous avons dû abandonner en salle de montage,
mais aussi de certaines idées
qui n'ont pas seulement survécues au processus,
mais qui en ont été renforcées.
L'année dernière, on a mis fin à un projet d'agriculture verticale automatisée.
Voilà la salade que nous faisons pousser.
Dans le monde, une personne sur neuf souffre de sous-nutrition.
Donc c'est un Moonshot qu'il faut absolument mettre en place.
L'agriculture verticale utilise dix fois moins d'eau,
et cent fois moins d'espace que l'agriculture conventionnelle.
On peut faire pousser de la nourriture près de l'endroit où elle sera consommée,
on n'a donc pas à la transporter sur de longues distances.
On a fait des progrès dans beaucoup de domaines
qui ont permis la récolte automatique, ou l'éclairage économique.
Malheureusement,
nous n'avons pas réussi à faire pousser les cultures de base verticalement.
Nous avons donc laissé tomber.
Voilà un autre problème.
Nous payons d'énormes coûts en ressources et en dégâts environnementaux
pour livrer des biens dans le monde entier.
Le développement économique de pays enclavés
est limité par le manque d'infrastructures de transport.
Une solution radicale ?
Un véhicule plus léger que l'air, à flottaison variable.
Cela aurait le potentiel nécessaire pour baisser,
au moins de manière globale,
le coût, le temps et l'empreinte carbone des échanges
sans avoir besoin de routes.
Nous en sommes arrivés à cette innovation technique capitale :
ensemble, nous pourrions réduire assez le coût
pour rendre ces échanges très peu chers,
ramenés au volume.
Mais aussi bon marché que ces échanges auraient pu être,
il aurait fallu près de 200 millions de dollars pour concevoir
et fabriquer le premier véhicule.
200 millions de dollars, c'est un prix beaucoup trop élevé.
À X, nous suivons un chemin particulier :
nous nous trompons, nous apprenons et nous créons de nouveaux concepts.
Nous ne pouvons pas dépenser ce prix
pour faire un essai
et voir si, oui ou non, cela fonctionne.
Si l'un de nos projets a un talon d'Achille,
nous devons le savoir au début, et pas au milieu du processus.
Donc nous avons aussi abandonné ce projet.
Découvrir une faille dans un projet ne veut pas toujours dire
qu'il faut arrêter ce projet.
Ça peut nous permettre de trouver une méthode plus productive.
Voici notre prototype de véhicule autonome,
que nous avons construit sans volant ni pédale de frein.
Pourtant, ce n'était pas notre objectif initial.
Avec 1,2 million de morts sur les routes, chaque année,
créer un véhicule autonome était un projet Moonshot tout trouvé.
Il y a trois ans et demi de cela,
nous testions des Lexus modernisées, pouvant se conduire toutes seules,
et cela marchait si bien que nous les avons données à d'autres chercheurs,
afin qu'ils nous disent ce qu'ils en pensaient.
Nous avons alors découvert
que notre idée de voitures prenant en charge la conduite
et ne s'en remettant au conducteur qu'en cas d'urgence
était une très mauvaise idée.
Ce n'était pas sûr
parce que les utilisateurs ne faisaient pas leur travail.
Ils ne restaient pas en alerte
au cas où la voiture aurait besoin de leur rendre le contrôle.
Il y a eu une crise dans l'équipe,
qui est revenue au point de départ.
Ils ont finalement trouvé une nouvelle, belle perspective.
Ils ont cherché à créer une voiture où le conducteur est vraiment un passager.
Il dit à la voiture l'endroit où il veut aller,
appuie sur un bouton
la voiture l'emmène toute seule d'un point A à un point B.
Nous sommes très contents
d'avoir eu cette idée aussi tôt dans le processus de création.
C'est la base de tout ce que nous avons construit depuis.
Maintenant, nos voitures ont conduit toutes seules plus de 2,2 millions de kms,
et on les trouve tous les jours
dans les rues de Mountain View en Californie, et d'Austin, au Texas.
L'équipe travaillant sur les voitures a changé de point de vue.
C'est l'une des devises d'X.
Parfois, changer de perspective importe plus que l'intelligence.
L'un de mes exemples favoris
est l'énergie éolienne.
Nous ne pouvons pas construire
une éolienne plus performante que les experts en la matière.
Néanmoins, nous avons trouvé le moyen d'aller plus haut dans le ciel,
et d'avoir accès à des vents plus forts, donc à plus d'énergie,
sans avoir à utiliser des centaines de tonnes d'acier pour y parvenir.
Notre cerf-volant Makani se hisse dans le ciel
en faisant tourner ses hélices, le long de ses ailes,
et tire une longe durant son ascension,
en produisant de l'énergie transmise à cette longe.
Une fois que la longe est en haut,
il fait des ronds dans le ciel.
Les hélices qui l'ont fait monter sont devenues des turbines volantes.
Et cela envoie de l'énergie le long de cette longe.
Nous n'avons pas encore trouvé une raison de laisser tomber,
et plus ce projet résiste, plus notre enthousiasme augmente
à l'idée que ce pourrait devenir un moyen moins coûteux et plus facile à réaliser
pour obtenir de l'énergie éolienne dans le monde.
Notre projet le plus fou est probablement le Projet Loon.
Nous essayons de faire marcher Internet à l'aide de ballons.
Un réseau de ballons dans la stratosphère
apporterait une connexion Internet aux zones rurales les plus isolées du monde.
Cela permettrait à plus de quatre milliards de personnes
n'ayant pas ou très peu d'accès à Internet, d'être connectées.
Mais on ne peut pas prendre une antenne-relais au hasard,
y attacher un ballon, et l'envoyer en l'air.
Les vents sont trop forts, le ballon ne résisterait pas,
et il serait trop haut pour être relié au sol.
Et voici le moment tant attendu.
Et si, à la place,
on laissait les ballons dériver
et on leur apprenait à manœuvrer dans le vent
pour qu'ils aillent là où nous voulons ?
Figurez vous que la stratosphère est balayée par des vents
de différentes vitesses, dans différentes directions, sur des couches minces.
Nous espérions, à l'aide d'algorithmes et de données sur les vents du monde,
réussir à manœuvrer les ballons
pour les faire aller plus ou moins haut dans la stratosphère
afin qu'ils rejoignent ces vents.
Il faudrait qu'on ait assez de ballons pour que,
dès qu'un ballon dérive en dehors de sa zone,
il y ait un autre ballon prêt à prendre sa place,
permettant une connexion Internet en continu,
tout comme nos téléphones qui passent par plusieurs antennes-relais.
quand on roule sur l'autoroute.
Nous savons que ce projet paraît fou,
le nom du projet nous le rappelle.
Donc, depuis 2012,
l'équipe Loon se focalise sur le travail qui semble le plus difficile
et donc le plus probable de mettre fin au projet.
La première étape
était d'établir une connexion Wi-Fi entre un ballon dans la stratosphère
et une antenne au sol.
Et ça a marché.
Je vous assure que beaucoup pariaient sur l'échec.
Nous avons donc continué.
Les ballons pourraient-ils être directement reliés à des portables,
pour que nous n'ayons pas à utiliser des antennes en intermédiaires ?
Oui.
Pourrait-il y avoir un débit suffisant
pour une véritable connexion Internet ?
Pour que les gens puissent faire plus que simplement s'envoyer des SMS ?
Les premiers tests n'ont permis d'avoir qu'à peine un mégabit par seconde,
mais maintenant cela peut aller jusqu'à 15 mégabits par seconde.
Assez pour voir un TedTalk.
Les ballons pourraient-ils communiquer dans les airs
pour étendre notre signal aux zones rurales plus reculées ?
C'est fait.
Les ballons de la taille d'une maison pourraient-ils rester plus de 100 jours
en hauteur en consommant moins de 5 %
de ce que consomment les ballons traditionnels ?
Finalement, oui.
Mais je vous promets que nous avons dû essayer plusieurs fois pour réussir.
Nous avons fabriqué des ballons ronds et argentés.
Nous avons aussi fabriqué des ballons en forme de traversins géants,
avec des ballons de la taille d'une baleine bleue.
Nous avons gâché beaucoup de ballons.
(Rires).
Comme la chose qui était le plus susceptible d'interrompre le projet
était de savoir si nous pouvions manœuvrer les ballons dans le ciel.
L'expérience déterminante a consisté à mettre un ballon dans un autre ballon.
Il y avait deux compartiments, l'un rempli d'air et l'autre d'hélium.
Le ballon aspirait de l'air pour se faire plus lourd,
ou laissait échapper de l'air pour se faire plus léger.
Et ces changements de poids lui permettaient de monter ou de descendre :
ce simple mouvement du ballon étant son mécanisme de pilotage.
Il flotte plus ou moins haut,
pour attraper des vents allant à la vitesse et dans la direction qu'il veut.
Est-ce suffisant pour qu'il navigue n'importe où dans le monde ?
Difficilement d'abord,
mais de mieux en mieux.
Notre dernier modèle de ballon
peut naviguer sur une zone verticale de plus de 3 kms
et peut se guider tout seul à l'endroit où où il veut aller, à 500 mètres près,
depuis une distance de plus de 20 000 kms.
Nous avons encore beaucoup à faire
pour améliorer le système et réduire ses coûts.
Mais l'année dernière, un ballon construit à peu de frais
a voyagé 19 fois autour du monde en 187 jours.
Donc on va persévérer.
(Applaudissements)
Aujourd'hui, nos ballons
remplissent toutes les tâches nécessaires pour fonctionner.
Nous discutons avec des entreprises de télécommunication,
et nous allons aller en Indonésie par exemple
afin de vraiment tester les ballons cette année.
Cela semble sans doute trop beau pour être vrai,
et vous avez raison.
Être audacieux
et travailler sur de gros projets risqués
rend les gens anxieux.
On ne peut pas crier sur les gens et les forcer à rater rapidement.
Ils résistent. Ils sont préoccupés.
« Qu'est-ce qui va m'arriver si j'échoue ?
Les gens vont se moquer de moi ?
Je serai viré ? »
J'ai commencé par vous parler de notre secret.
Je vais vous expliquer comment on le réalise.
Le seul moyen de pousser les gens à travailler sur des projets risqués,
à avoir des idées audacieuses,
et à faire face aux difficultés du projet avant toute chose,
est de leur montrer que c'est le chemin le plus simple.
Nous travaillons dur à X pour que les gens n'aient pas peur d'échouer.
Les équipes abandonnent leurs projets
dès qu'ils comprennent que le projet est voué à l'échec,
parce qu'ils seront félicités pour ça.
Ils seront applaudis.
Ils auront des embrassades.
Leurs managers, moi notamment, leur taperont dans la main.
Ils auront des promotions grâce à ça.
Nous augmentons chaque personne trouvant une raison de mettre fin à un projet,
dans des équipes allant de deux à trente personnes.
Nous croyons aux rêves dans notre usine Moonshot.
Mais le scepticisme enthousiaste
n'est pas l'ennemi d'un optimisme sans bornes.
C'est en fait son parfait partenaire.
Il déverrouille le potentiel de chaque idée.
Nous pouvons créer le futur dont nous rêvons.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)